dude it'd be funny if this was an
entrance to a nice ass restaurant in all
videos you see people walking
that'll be hilarious and we're just
filming yeah
we pay the bills all right
[Music]
all right have you guys ever been to a
secret restaurant no no no
you've never been one I've never been
what's a secret restaurant I can speak
easy huh oh like a restaurant that's
hidden but is it that secret then yeah
there's a couple in Vegas they're kind
of cool like you go in it looks like a
bookstore and then you have to say a
secret password and let you in there's
another one in Vegas what do you say
like bubble tea or something I forgot
there's another one you go to a a uh a
bar and then you go downstairs and it's
the restaurant but you have to tell them
Secrets but don't you want customers
though because if it's secret and no one
comes then you can't get mad but like
the scarcity huh oh I'm gonna tell you
guys some cool secret restaurants around
the US oh cool it's not that a secret
anymore let's tell everybody here's one
this is called Lenox and it's in New
York it looks like this it's like a cool
little you know that's in John Wick I
don't see nothing you get to it
here's the entrance whoa It's to the
left of that pillar behind that curtain
really that looks like a hotel it is a
hotel oh wow that's pretty tight that's
how they hit it with a curtain yeah but
it's not that curtain it's the small one
oh it's pretty cool right wow that's
really cool 5 out of 10.
how do you rate that one zero it sucks
the food better be good we're gonna
we're gonna judge all the secret
entrances to these restaurants right it
better be super secret all right because
the more movie The more like Bruce Wayne
Batman the better there better be a
bookshelf yeah I want to [__] go like
that and then the whole place just a
hole opens and I fall and then go
through a tube yeah oh sorry that wasn't
the entrance that was the entrance to a
burger place this is the entrance to
that one it's in the subway where this
door is and the suit guy is standing in
front of us oh that's pretty cool
it's a curtain dude
and be like what's behind this yeah this
is like in the subway there's this one
nice door where's that at that is the
one in New York that one looks a little
sus it's like dude are they doing drugs
in here like it looks like a gambling
place or something the other one was
also in New York and that just goes to a
like a burger joint there's a place in
La if you go it's called Barbara Brigade
you go to the front desk I swear to God
if you go I'm here for the lobster
they'll take it to the back where the
sword go there yeah just try it let's
try it don't take it to the back yeah
I'll take you and they got Lobster
chowder yeah dude there's a restaurant
there's a restaurant back there what the
hell are you talking about it's just all
part of the app don't even worry about
it just keep saying the line yeah
I got a secret menu on my at my place oh
really it's a soft serve we have four
items we have Coco hair we have Diamond
Hair we have locals delight and we have
matcha lava can you tell us what the
flavors are no it's a seed no because I
don't remember it specifically but like
it's got like it's it's got uh guava
puree
you got black sesame jelly no I got I
got access to me yet but but here's the
thing you go up to this place called
jumbi Waikiki in in Waikiki Hawaii and
you tell them one I want the secret soft
serve stuff locals Delight or something
like that right and then you buy you get
it and then behind the building there's
a beach you can eat it
secret Beach
wow what's it called Waikiki Beach at
Lionheart Jiu Jitsu Academy Colleen's
Academy yeah um are we sure we want to
tell the people there we want to tell
people this you know you can go to the
gym and say hey
I'm here to [__] up black belts and then
that's yeah that's the secret code I'm
here to [__] up black belts
enter you into it yeah yeah yeah yeah
then you got to take out your credit
card you get to pay full membership
I like that yeah yeah yeah I like that
you pay for a year and a half
yeah
yeah it's an installment at the secret
Beach behind uh June beat you gotta find
this one snorkeler and then we got to
sneak up on him yeah he's looking at
little eels and [__] yeah you gotta grab
a snorkel pipe and you gotta go
I'm here for the lobster
now you go like this you get your finger
you go
it's like oh
this gives you a lobster yeah there's
um there's a restaurant that's tight
we really thought did you guys know
there's a restaurant inside the Grand
Canyon Caverns
what that's so cool oh I've seen is that
where the whole I think there's a hotel
there too sick man have you ever seen
have you ever seen those things where
like whenever they have like caves you
could like spend the night there and
then like that's pretty absolutely
that's scary dude that's so cool
stalagmatites
and tights but that's crazy that it's um
so it's on that little platform that you
saw and it's it's 210 feet below ground
and it's a four table 16 seat restaurant
Airbnb that you actually have to like
snorkel down to and then you come out of
this air pocket and it's just this like
small bedroom you have like your kitchen
stuff like that they also deliver pizza
to you oh my God but you have to spend
like the whole 24 hours and you stay
there you're under water dude
how does the pizza get there yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's gonna be all soaked and
then like a water sloppy Pizza dude you
open it it's like I didn't order Seafood
pizza that's crazy YouTube it I swear
it's a thing that's [__] cool it's
got like a waterproof [__] thing and
he swims down there and delivers it dude
I just pictured the whole box just
getting soaked and they opened it
there's a squid I didn't order this
Seafood you're gonna eat it dude here's
a crazy one I didn't even know this was
here in Little Tokyo there's a secret
sushi restaurant called Sushi kaneoshi
kanayoshi it looks like this
whoa what the hell is this
you know what that looks like that looks
like you would eat the sushi off a naked
lady or something like unless how fancy
it looks it's in um it's on second in
San Pedro it's guarded by two homeless
people right it's a basement Sushi box
you have to get the courage to say
excuse me
don't say it it's a sushi bar in the
basement and you have to go down the
stairs at the parking garage on second
or something instead of up like you got
to go down and oh [__] what we didn't
even know what else that's like in our
backyard whoa what what if there's no
one
shot
[Laughter]
in Miami there's uh like a upscale
restaurant that's through this door of a
taco restaurant that's cool yeah you go
in there you see a bunch of like fancy
people dressed in yeah
exactly what happened to me yeah that
happened to me on Melrose it's gone now
but on Melrose there was a grilled
cheese restaurant that had a really
amazing grilled cheese it was like the
size of this part of the room and uh
I kept seeing people like so you have
your kitchen right there right and it's
they're the guy with the counter he's
sitting there like taking order behind
him there's a kitchen
I would go there like pretty often and I
brought these uh Olympic skaters with me
one day I was like I gotta try grilled
cheese place we're sitting there Olympic
skaters yeah hanging out and then all
these people in suits and dresses
started walking out of the back and they
were like what the hell is that and then
they we were like should we go and just
walk back there and see and we're like
all right this dude stops us we'll just
not do it so we got up and we walked
literally behind the counter the guy
acts like he doesn't see us he's just
like standing here we go all the way to
the back of the kitchen like a kitchen
you'd see in an action movie when
everyone's fighting through it or like
Goodfellas yeah so we go to the kitchen
it's the freaking fridge and the fridge
you open the fridge
nice ass restaurant yeah yeah
a whole like nice ass steak steak that
is an entrance they have a uh in
Hollywood though they do uh it's like a
fridge that you walk through I think
it's a bar though oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
um good time good time Dave wins yeah
this one like they don't advertise this
place at all and then you go in there
and and we had a nice dinner and like
steak so you dropped your grilled cheese
yeah what'd you say let me say but then
don't eat it the place went back girl
because nobody [__] knows it's there
that's the downside down so it literally
went bankrupt you really got it that's
your fault for wanting me to be a secret
yeah yeah you're saving cool for a
little bit dude it was they didn't see
covet coming I'm so lucky that I we
found out the way we did because we
literally didn't know no one said
nothing that guy didn't say anything
we just literally you guys explore you
can see that the dude at the restaurant
was like nice cool these guys
they're adventurers yeah it's exactly
like this it's like a normal restaurant
in the back it's the real thing and it's
kind of like on Rose you got all these
rows of stores and shops and sometimes
there's Courtyards in the middle that
you can't see and that's where they
built that restaurant so um when you got
there was there a host was there
absolutely as soon as we opened the
fridge someone's like hi welcome to
Fuddruckers
[Laughter]
dude that's so funny imagine that
tableside grilled cheese it's not as
good restaurant you're like working so
hard you're like what is going on hi
welcome to Hollywood Applebee's
there's another uh cool place in New
York that the entrance is so it's in an
art gallery cool but the entrance is
behind one of the paintings oh wow
that's [__] cool see that's the kind
of work I want to see yeah not a curtain
you know what now I'm thinking about a
shower curb all you do is this yeah
[Laughter]
I know
yeah dude there's a door yeah let me
climb through something give me a
bookshelf yeah oh let me open this table
and like there's stairs in there you
know like something there's a bookshelf
entrance one too let me sit on a [__]
piano that turns the other way
[Applause]
that's a [__] Dream by the way let me
go to a [__] fireplace and like pull
the wrong lever and then it just goes
and pull up the poker so Marianne's in
San Francisco the entrance is in this
lounge and it's behind that bookshelf
right there oh that's cool
is Magic Castle
yeah you enter through like a like a
like a bookshelf yeah yeah that's not
magic but I I think you gotta say oh you
gotta say what's what's the code word I
can't tell you
oh that's weird there's a place called
Blind Tiger and that's in Florida this
place they said the entrance is past the
bathroom of a different restaurant oh
that's kind of weird right so I I'm
assuming that these secret restaurants
typically don't last very long depending
on how good the food is yeah honestly I
don't know because the one that I knew
about it was gone in like two years
or do you think they move because
they're like ah people too many people
know us you know what's funny I think
they I think they tried to move because
I remember seeing it in like Silver Lake
and then it just never opened and then
it was gone so maybe like
yeah I've been a one in Highland Park
actually but it was like a barber shop
and then the back was like a really cool
really Swanky bar but there was no
secret it would be just a guy in a door
it'd be funny if this was an entrance to
a nice ass restaurant in all videos you
see people walking
that'll be hilarious and we're just
filming yeah
they don't even think it's a real show
hey do you think some of these secret
restaurants like are also a secret from
the government too because then nobody
knows that they're there oh so they
don't pay tax pay taxes they're just
making money off of people because
they're there's no location you know
they don't even follow code yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah because the front is the
grilled cheese place it's not you know
that's how you launder Monday yeah yeah
but how do you put an address on a
secret place yeah if it's owned by
another place I never thought about that
what are they just subletting dude
that's what all it is like hey you want
to open up but it's a secret nobody
knows it's there so I wonder if it's
legal to make a secret restaurant access
be like if you held one in three on an
elevator and it like that's cool you
gotta program it that takes you to a
certain floor then you're gonna get less
people in your restaurant because
someone's gonna [__] that up and they're
gonna be like [__] this this
I think it'd be cool if we turned our
entrance of the studio into a secret
door
foreign
[Music]